topic of the purpose of life i think
everybody like we're here for a reason
and actually you know what um i was
watching iron man recently
and iron man he gets out of um he gets
out of the caves
and he said if i'm still alive
then there must be a reason on the topic
of death i know a lot of people try to
avoid it and so on you know like every
day you wake up in the morning you want
to say to yourself am i prepared to die
today am i prepared to die today and
that's got to be like in your mind all
that's like your life mission and ladies
and gentlemen
here on the dean show
he is making his appearance
mohammed sharif here on the dean show
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
this is
[Music]
wake up there are over 300 million
americans that don't know what islam is
this is why we are opening the dean
center the first of its kind 35 000
square foot tawa center and masjid to
show america the beautiful message of
islam inshallah with your help and
donations we can close on the property
launch nationwide programs a
state-of-the-art production studio for
online content and an on-site dawah
center to show what true islam is donate
right now may god almighty allah reward
all of you
[Music]
assalamu alaykum
please be with you peace be with you too
now
the
million dollar question is what is going
on we've had everyone
on the program we had sheikh waleed
basuni we had yasir bijaz yah said this
that everyone from because you're the
ceo of al maghrib and we've had our eye
on you where you been the audience wants
to know not just me you know what's
interesting actually you know i'm going
to shout out to my father-in-law every
time we do a muller institute class he
doesn't show up
and all he does is watch the dean's show
so i said
you know what i'm gonna come on the dean
show just so my father-in-law can
benefit
thank you very much no problem made this
pleasure
thank you thank you may this be a
benefit to the whole world let's watch
it because you got some knowledge and
you can't be stingy with it so we're
gonna pick your brain so we can all
learn and i can learn and then the whole
world can learn who's watching it'd be
my pleasure thank you
muslim identity muslim is one who has
chosen to consciously submit to the one
god along without any partners equals
nothing like that
and just identity in general people are
looking for someone something to
identify with and when you're not
identifying with the right people the
right
thing you're identifying with the wrong
thing so let's talk about this sure
sure okay so um human beings i think in
order for human beings to like cultivate
life on earth they have this
sheep they call it cheap mentality and
people kind of make it into a negative
but it actually it brings unity amongst
people it's like you can find common
people you get together with them now
this hurting that happens with human
beings
what we're talking about identity
if somebody doesn't consciously come
along and guide them in the right
direction then you know the word i would
say is like shaytan or the devil the
evil one basically becomes you know the
herder of of these people and their and
their thoughts and their minds so
leaders need to come along
guided people who
pull people in the right direction
for a moment tell us now you said
shaytan the devil is this real is this
something from hollywood bollywood
there's really satanic forces that are
working talk about this briefly before
we move forward
is there satanic force i think you know
there's um obviously when you have good
you just take it to the other spectrum
you have you have bad right you have
heat take it away you have cold for
those people just want to understand
that concept that it might be like you
have you have extreme good and then you
that good starts getting pulled away
pulled away until it becomes bad so i
mean that obviously we know in islam
about shaitaan and it's in the history
of all the scriptures so
our agenda here
is to help people
to understand
the true purpose of life
why they're here who their creator is
and we're inviting them to
what's good
okay and now
before we can even get to that a lot of
times there's confusion out there
because people are confused like who am
i so again they're mimicking mocking the
rappers the hip-hop stars the actors and
actresses so how can we get them away
from mocking people who will only lead
them to destruction and considering
mocking the best of people which were
the prophets and the last and final
messenger is the best example please
talk to us okay sure so if you look at
say a school that has a dress code yes
and i remember once reading a cartoon or
and in this cartoon it was a bunch of
kids from another school that didn't
have a dress code and they were saying
ha ha look at those
foolish kids there they have you know
a specific uniform but the cartoon was
making fun of the kids that were saying
this because they all had their hats on
backwards they all had their jeans even
backwards and their shirts and all of
that stuff in other words that everybody
is basically copying right and that's
human nature that we're gonna copy now
when you say
who becomes our role model basically the
role model is defined by the television
it's by the camera so the people that
get that stage are the actors and
actresses they're the musicians and so
on and so forth so you look at our
children and and our generation it's
like a whole nation of people are being
raised up that this is their role model
now back in the olden days if you take
out television out of the picture then
who are the role models those are people
who are
actively involved in the community
people who are you know doing good
things in the community that's the
person that they see everywhere because
you don't see actors and actresses
everywhere you see the the leaders in
the community hence say when i was
growing up somebody was a role model for
me were like the older youth the older
boys in the community who were doing
activities in the local masjid and i was
able to you know absorb from that but if
i was to go to a muslim kid today and
say who's your role model you know it's
going to be wolverine it's going to be
spider-man it's going to be something
like that yeah yeah now now tell us
why is it do you feel again
that when we mention like let's say
moses okay peace be upon him abraham
peace be upon him jesus christ peace be
upon him peace be upon him the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him and we see we
we we we have so much utterance and
respect for them but now it's not cool
like to bring them up this is weird but
to talk about
you know
brad pitt
keanu reeves
j.lo
we can have a conversation sure if you
talk about these great men and the
legacy they left behind i got time for
that
why do you think this is
well i guess that's coming from um from
a culture that is trying to pull away
from those things right so obviously um
here comes these religions they come
along and and and everybody everybody's
saying you know i'm the one following
the truth somebody says no not them
follow me follow me so that the names
that are being thrown out are the names
that you've mentioned yeah people are
just like throwing them out but so the
person who's listening to that they just
don't want to hear it anymore and so
their solution is to like shut down so
what i would say is that no that's not
the solution the solution not to put
your head in the sand and shut
everything out the solution is to
will search out what is the truth
there's a lot of chatter out there
there's a lot of hiss and noise but
somebody needs to basically say well
what was the unifying message of these
prophets and really you know go to a
higher ground and look at that and you
will see that they're all unified that
there's no god but allah
how can we get people to
to because obviously if you're you're
hungry you're going to eat okay but now
if you're not hungry your belly's full
no matter how
great that gourmet dish is dessert is
you're not really interested right okay
so how can we get people to really to
consider
this this proposition proposal to take
this matter seriously because the
lights will go on the party will end
sure and you can only acquire so much
wealth how do we get them because
sharing is caring right we love our
brothers in humanity and we want them to
be our brothers and family you know
what's what's interesting about your
question is like this person their
stomach is full even if it's a gourmet
field as soon as you said that i'm
thinking to myself that i actually i
disagree that their stomach is full
their stomach is empty empty and if
anything it's their heart that's empty
right so allah puts something in the
heart of everybody it's like a gps so
even the person who wants to deny god
will not deny god they'll say i believe
in a higher being because they can't
shut off their brain they can't shut off
their heart allah is you know like it's
he's beckoning them to to come to him so
this person is actually starving
but they're saying that they're full so
they go into drugs they go into you know
into fornication they go into all these
different areas but they're still empty
on the inside so when we want to come
along and this is even for a muslim
who's trying to pass on the message
rather than coming to this person you
know head on and say hey follow the
prophets i say we address the problem
from an angle of you know what's the
purpose of your life
let's shut off this pain and let's test
something out so for example somebody
who um there was a rapper like really
intense rapper and he became muslim
later and he was doing alcohol and drugs
and you know and the whole deal
and then there was a muslim who invited
him to pray yeah and he said once his
head went on the ground the sweetness of
his forehead touching that carpet and
he's like you know i'm hooked and that's
what i'm talking about they're starving
and they're actually trying to fill
themselves but it's not getting the job
done it's like eating cotton candy right
eating cotton candy let's take a break
and we'll be right back with more here
on the dean show
[Music]
matter of fact you get testimonies from
christians in eastern europe thanking
god for the rule of muslims when the
ottoman empire came unoccupied because
now they can have tolerance and
religious freedom
i declare from today there is none
worthy to be worshipped except allah
alone the one god the one god because
the muslims would not
you know force you to convert to the
religion and the prophet muhammad is the
last messenger of allah that's the same
in aramaic jesus said allah so it's the
same god
[Music]
help us purchase this property to build
the dean center
donate right now may god almighty allah
reward all of you brothers and sisters
back here on the dean show
talking about
serious issues
you've mentioned the purpose of life
many people they know the purpose of
their job they know the purpose of many
other things but now the purpose of life
the crucial question people aren't
reflecting aren't asking this question
why do you think this is
okay you know um
obviously they're not asking the
question they might be asking the
question but they might be shutting it
off
so it's like the purpose of life i don't
know
so let me just move on right but when it
comes to the topic of the purpose of
life i think everybody like we're here
for a reason and actually you know what
um i was watching iron man recently
and iron man he gets out of um he gets
out of the caves
and he said if i'm still alive
then there must be a reason yeah and i
said that that's an interesting point
and even you know it was it was
emotional for me i'm watching iron man
i'm emotional because if i'm still alive
here then there's a reason for me to be
here right and anybody who's watching
for you for anybody it's like when did
you think that you had no purpose
right and who convinced you of that and
who led you in that direction so you
have a purpose and if you can accept
that there even a pen
as simple as a pen if it has no purpose
once the ink dries up you throw it away
it's worthless now are you worthless
and you'd say no i'm not worthless i'm a
human being so then the the value comes
from purpose right so what is the
purpose
why are you here on earth and
alhamdulillah like questions like that
where other people get confused in islam
we don't get confused we actually know
exactly what our purpose is and then
that's where the peace comes from is
knowing what our purpose is now now for
our not yet muslim audience you said two
arabic words sure so they don't think
we're saying some code words here you
said alhamdulillah and you said islam
okay please define those please okay so
islam is the religion of islam literally
means it comes from a root called selema
which means peace and islam is like a
way of life a way of like peaceful life
that's islam
to worship allah alone and allah meaning
god alone and to follow the message of
prophet muhammad peace be upon him and
the second word
which is
thankfulness right so alhamdulillah
literally means
thank you god
i was actually reading a bumper sticker
it's an it's a habit that muslims do
in the afternoon and the mornings to
thank god very specifically and i was
reading a bumper sticker as i was doing
this muslim habit of thanking god saying
alhamdulillah the bumper sticker said
have you thanked god today i'm like i'm
doing it right now we're doing it all
the time
okay we we mentioned purpose of light
now where does someone who's confused
they see all these religions okay and
they say you know what it's all the same
i'm just gonna do my own thing how do we
get them to think
outside the box and how do we get them
to think serious and how do they
differentiate what's the true way of
life the way of life god wants that
person to live from all the different
man-made religions okay sure so people
are confused with the different
religions and and we've all gone through
this stage even when i was younger i
said you know what it's not about islam
it's not about this i'm going to find
the religion of truth and i actually
came to the conclusion that i found it
yeah right so this is what this would be
my recommendation in the muddle and in
the in the quicksand and mud of
everybody disagreeing and yapping and so
on i'd recommend the person to step
above that okay now you've got higher
principles that unify multiple people
now usually people who have reached the
higher principle stage they kind of like
reject religion at that point they're
like i'm just going to take the higher
principles but i'm saying take the
higher principles and you'll find that
those higher principles are found in
islam right so for example if people are
saying oh worship this idol worship you
know this worship that and you'd say
well i just want to worship god boom you
came to a higher level instead of
rejecting the religions
that's what the message of islam is
worship one god alone one god one god
that's it enough and that's the basis of
everything in islam the other thing is
realize that um
god created you
so inside of you i was saying earlier
about a gps your body can sense when
some you know there's some you know
funny stuff going on and the body
doesn't you know it doesn't accept that
so when you actually go to the islamic
laws
your body is naturally inclined to that
so very often you'll hear islam and then
you're like that makes sense you hear
something else about islam that makes
sense that makes and you're like the
whole religion is like that
is there anything just to assuage any
fears in islam do you have like rolling
around with rats you know beating
yourself over the head with a knife or a
whip and you know because people you
know they might think these things
that's right it's weird it is to us but
what do we got to say about that is
there anything like that in islam i mean
obviously the the actual the cool thing
about islam is that there's a set
criteria of how to check whether
something like that is authentic or not
a falsification test a falsification
test in islam and a lot of times you
know when you have with other religions
you know some person of authority tells
you something and just kind of like okay
i gotta accept it because he's a person
of authority in islam
you don't really have that authority
figure you've got authority tests okay
so if somebody says something to me he's
like muhammad i had a dream last night
that you know this is the way to go to
paradise i'd be like whatever
right i'm like let's put it through the
filters yeah and i actually studied that
in detail automatically as soon as
somebody starts talking i'm like boom
boom here are the filters where did you
get this from so if you're gonna make
something up like you made it up then
you're going to need to have proof
right and if you're going to um
if you're going to quote somebody else
you're going to say so and so said this
right then you're going to need to bring
up the citation where did that come from
so with those two rules what's your
proof or where's your citation
then you've got like that's one of the
basic filters right there so in islam we
have the truth and is backed up with
proof of course
and we're not doing it's not blind faith
for sure there's no such thing as blind
faith in islam so how before we submit
ourselves did we actually you know even
on the point of the blind faith i would
say that even the scholars of the past
they would say that it's not even
permissible for somebody to accept my
opinion unless they know the proof
right so the whole concept of blind
faith they're even protecting the future
followers saying that
like you have to know the proof so
here's the proof and a lot sometimes
people they just drop the proof of like
we'll just take whatever you say but
they're saying like no you have to know
the proof because the authority's coming
from the proof it's not coming from the
person so it's not where you start
digging in islam things start getting
confused and they're just it's a mystery
man just just believe no is that that's
not how it is absolutely not that's
amazing seriousness of taking this topic
serious death can we just that is what
helped me get my act together okay was
reflecting about death is this a serious
matter
you know ultimately you know on the
topic of death i know a lot of people
try to avoid it and so on you want to
live your life um
prepared to die yeah right so in other
words you know recently in my city there
was an earthquake
when an earthquake strikes that's not
the time to start thinking about death
you know like every day you wake up in
the morning you want to say to yourself
am i prepared to die today am i prepared
to die today and that's got to be like
in your mind all that's like your life
mission is preparing to die so that when
the time of death does come along it's
like you've been preparing for this your
whole life right and that's what life is
all about it's not about oh let's live
in the moment it's like let's live in
the moment with our hearts in the
hereafter so that we'd make the right
decisions in the moment now living life
according to god's will not your desires
paradise is that guaranteed for an
individual then if you do all the good
that god wants you to do and you die in
a good righteous state worshipping only
the one god following his last and final
messenger which obviously precedes all
the other messengers
the glad tidings is this what we're
seeking paradise it is it is but i would
also add something to what you said is
that human beings they make mistakes yes
right so we're not saying what other
people of other religions have said that
you know what as long as you accept this
and that you're going to go to paradise
we know as human beings islam is a
natural way and a person will make
mistakes yeah so it's not a um just
a utopia or ideal or perfect person so
in islam the prophet peace be upon him
said prophet muhammad peace be upon him
said that every son of adam every human
being makes mistakes right so when i
make a mistake as i've made you know
today like hundreds of mistakes just in
this day i'm thinking myself i'm a human
being i'm not an angel and that's what
islam teaches me i actually tell you
this this story i was at a um a tony
robbins convention yes right and i was
sitting beside a jewish man
and um and i was listening to what tony
robbins was saying i was getting excited
that's the big tall guy yeah the big
tall guy he's kind of tall
and um and then i was so happy i'm like
i can i can implement what this guy is
saying and my jewish friend was saying
to me that you know what he was feeling
sad i said why are you sad he said
because what tony's saying
is
he's like i know that one week from now
i'm not going to be able to keep up with
that and i said you know what that's the
beauty of islam because i'm not worried
about keeping up with it because i know
that as a human being i'm going to dip
and when the dip happens i just turn it
back around
right so in islam when a person makes a
mistake they ask allah for forgiveness
and allah one of god's one of his names
is the oft forgiving and he loves to
hear our forgiveness so i'm like i'm a
human being i made a mistake today oh
allah please forgive me for this. and i
know that by me asking forgiveness i'm
actually coming closer to god god
almighty is the most loving the most
merciful the forgiving we'll leave on
that note for a second and we'll be
right back from more on the dean's show
he is still born about 60 years ago in
former yugoslavia today's bosnia after
second world war can you imagine today
you have one child killed too much it's
important that we realize that islam is
a gift so we believe that in the
teachings of jesus what is left there is
truth in there
[Music]
but the truth has been mixed up with
paganism and with nature worship
assalamu alaikum would you like to be
part of the first ever mega tawa center
in the u.s
a 35 000 square foot former church on a
four
acre plot
equipped with a masjid
a dawa center a tv recording studio a
dao outreach program and much much more
over the last decade one of the most
successful and consistent dawah series
has been the dean show and now we want
to help our brother eddie take it to the
next level from the dean show to the
dean center inshallah where it's going
to be this megadawa center in florida
what we need now is to reach the next
goal which is seven hundred thousand
dollars and we need your help doing so
so please my brothers and sisters donate
today with whatever you can and share
the
share this link with everyone you know
because everyone who donates through you
sharing the link you're going to get
part of the reward as well inshallah
ta'ala which is
back here with
my brother your brother sheikh mohammed
asharif that's sharif and we're really
i'm thankful that you are here with us
thank you very much and it's just a
pleasure being here thank you and
inshallah we can have you back again
sometime
now we're talking about we started off
talking about identity okay so we define
somewhat just gave people somewhat of a
taste of what islam is about okay so if
you push towards identifying more with
islam
the creator
way of life that he's given to us to
live by okay what are more of the
positive outcomes that you'll have as
opposed to identifying again with the tv
stars with the rap stars etc etc okay
perfect okay so
allah our god has
he created human beings he knows like
the master plan of where we're all going
and what brings
what will bring us prosperity and what
will not so for example something like
alcohol as a muslim i don't drink
alcohol so the people that are caught up
and they're addicted and it's causing
all the harms i'm already protected from
that because allah protected when it
comes to um you know the mortgage crisis
in the u.s
as a muslim i'm not involved in
taking or receiving interest
so because of that i don't have a house
i didn't get involved so when the market
collapses i'm already saved from it
because i was never there in the first
place right and so the only one who's
saving me from all of this is allah
almighty and it's because i've taken
those promises
god's message and implemented in my life
and i've been saved from these harms
maybe in the short term if somebody was
to say hey just have a glass of wine it
seems like oh i'm missing out or so on
and so forth but look at the long
long-term effects of those things and
you realize that islam has protected the
believers and sometimes i'm like with my
wife and i'll say you know what we
really need to be thankful for this
religion of islam because of how many
vices we've been protected from because
of islam
big time big time and we thank the
creator of the heavens and earth for
guiding us to the truth and protecting
us
and tell us now for the muslim
that is
a little nervous about his identity so
you'll say and you'll be happy to see
the person and you want to give them the
salami salaam lake hey how you doing
or you say you know uh muhammad is that
you no it's actually mo
what advice do you have for them okay so
when a person i have this um this
criteria i tell a person that you know
if you're going to a park to pray
and you feel nervous
whose permission do you need if they
gave you permission you would feel
comfortable praying so i'm like what is
it is it the government that you want to
give you permission to pray is it you
know like a non-muslim walking by you
want them to give you permission to pray
who if they gave you permission you
would be fine
and then when they if you identify who
that person is because even in the
example that you gave they've got a
co-worker that they've actually made
like their slave master right and they
become a slave to them it's like uh well
i can't tell you what my real name is
because slave master so and so and that
person doesn't even know they were made
this late it's like arbitrary they've
put people in their lives above you know
themselves and i would say so when i'm
going to pray and i start to feel
nervous i say to myself i don't need
anybody's permission to pray and nobody
is my slave master i'm a free man right
land of the free home of the brave and
that's what it is muslims need to be
you don't need anybody's permission to
pray to allah now we want to talk to our
sisters who we love so much and they
also have an identity the the muslim
identity but some of the muslim sisters
they're a little more scared about the
environment the people might say so they
leer away from wearing the proper
identity to hijab what advice do you
have for them okay it's it's the same
concept as well it's um
[Music]
we were saying earlier about kind of
like the sheep mentality we want to
identify with a group of people when
you're living in an area in a community
that's not worshipping allah you
actually have to go against the that
sheep reaction and you've got to say you
know what i'm a leader i'm not a sheep
here so what the sister you know that's
this you know the pull of the sheep the
pull of the crowd or is she gonna pull
away and identify herself so she really
does have a big test but here is the
beautiful thing for muslim sisters is
that because at an early age they're
like dressing differently
they have to become stronger at such an
early age so their identity in fact if
you take a muslim man and a muslim woman
a muslim woman who's like wearing hijab
she's usually much stronger than the man
because her identity has been you know
brought up all these years and that
interestingly is that protection they
always speak about hijab as a protection
a lot of people don't realize that your
identity is being protected and your
character and your strength is being
protected because you're not becoming a
sheep when you wear that closing
comments and suggestions for those who
are having identity crisis
if you have an identity crisis i say
invoke the sheep okay and by that i mean
that you will have a sheep meant uh a
sheep reaction so get with good
companionship go to your local masjid
find some good people and and say
basically like i want i want you to be
my shepherd right and i want to be in in
this companionship so if you with a
group of three four people that don't
swear
and you say a swear word they're kind of
shy away from that you'll feel bad and
you'll start changing your vocabulary
with a group like that and that would be
my suggestion getting some good
companionship we started with peace we
end with peace
almighty allah reward you thank you
thank you very much and that was my
brother and your brother
sheikh mohammed al-sharif here on the
dean show giving us some great advice
establish your identity and the creator
of the heavens and earth has told you
what your identity needs to be you need
to be a muslim one who has
chosen consciously not by coercion but
has made a rational decision that i want
to do god's will i want to do all the
good that the creator of the heavens and
earth has told me to do
and then the reward is paradise jannah
so do this good beseech him ask him pray
to him repent to him alone without any
partners co-equals no one nothing is
like god and pray to that one god
when the going gets tough
or whenever you're in distress he is the
only one that can answer that call your
prayers
and we'll see you next time continue to
tune in every week to the dean show
until then
peace be unto you
[Music]
wake up there are over 300 million
americans that don't know what islam is
this is why we are opening the dean
center the first of its kind 35 000
square foot tawa center and masjid to
show america the beautiful message of
islam inshallah with your help and
donations we can close on the property
launch nationwide programs a
state-of-the-art production studio for
online content and an on-site dawah
center to show what true islam is
donate right now may god almighty allah
reward all of you
[Music]